you will learn by the end of the day you
should learn
what bioinformatics actually means
uh if you google a bioinformatics you're
going to get millions and millions of
records in google which means it's an
important term to know
um and this is a definition that i
have come up with and this is a
definition i hope
will make sense to everyone and we're
all talking about
big data big data big data so what i'm
going to talk to you about
what are the challenges we're facing
today because of the big data
and also where is all this big data
actually coming from
uh that elia was talking to you about
all different research projects
that we can do and how can we look at
diseases
um so i'm going to introduce you to all
the where the data is actually coming
from
and what it means and how we can
actually use so so today we're just
going to get introduced to the big data
where all this data is coming from and
because
of all of this big data we have given
birth to your whole new field
of genomics right so that is what we're
going to be
focusing on today so now before we
define what bioinformatics is
i want to talk to you about what is
informatics
study of how information is collected
stored
manipulated classified organized
retrieved visualized it's all too
complex right so
and how close how does it differ from
information technology i t right we all
hear about it
i.t experts so how does informatics
actually differ from
information technology information
science
computer science so all of them are
all pretty much belong to the same
family
right so it's all about data it how you
collect data
what kind of data you collect as a
material right so you go shopping
and all your you know the shoppers and
everything they're collecting data as
well so pretty much we're breathing in
and breathing out
data today right so for example we are
in the middle of a pandemic right
covered 19.
how many publications do you think that
we have actually had on covet 19
in the last six months any guesses how
many pub how many published papers are
out there
that's data right so what do you all
think how many papers do you think we
have right now
on covet 19 in the last six months since
we started getting into the spanning
week
any guesses 1030
it's actually thirty thousand so you can
see the
entire world is working so that's data
right so that's what resa
um elai was talking about research how
do you review literature
so there are like thirty thousand
publications so you can see every
second we are generating data now
importance to everyday life can we live
without informatics today
right my personal view is we cannot
everything is about data
anything you do is data so i don't think
we can live without informatics today
right absolutely not so every day we are
touched influenced by informatics
so i'm sure that you all have a facebook
account twitter account these are all
one of the most famous
in fact this was actually created by a
high school student
uh so we are all looking at data all
over the place right so there is
scientific data as well coming out of
all of this now so we are actually
living in a data centric world
and we are also we have lots of
devices accusation devices to collect
this data
and every single one of us is actually
creating content
creating data and the biggest challenge
is
how can we actually meaningfully use
this data
to get information from this
get the information and how do we
actually convert this to
meaningful knowledge and how can we use
this data to
use this key to advances in sciences in
different disciplines how are we going
to use this data right
so of course we are going to be focused
on biological data
right so no escape now all of us need to
learn how to deal with data
and data keeps coming and all of these
different
tools and there's lots of different
disciplines that we
and and we need all of you to collect
the collect and
disseminate and actually analyze this
data
so the whole goal is for us to take this
data
get relevant information from it and
transform that
information to knowledge from knowledge
then we can actually see
how best to use the data and go to the
next
step right now you all would have
actually realized a lot of different
omics right so there are different uh
types of omics that's there and i'm just
going to put bioinformatics
in the perspective in this whole world
of informatics
so american medical informatics
association
has actually come up with all of these
different omics
and we need all of these homics we need
a collaboration between data from all of
these different omics
and we have each one is trying to give
us different
levels right so we have biomedical
informatics we have health informatics
we have imaging informatics we have
clinical informatics we have public
health informatics
so each one is dealing with different
aspects right so
imaging is based on you know it's
tissues and
organs and then individual patients is
clinical informatics because you gather
data from patients
you then you have population society
society and then which is public health
which is all
all of us are doing you know part of the
public health informatics
so but what we are going to focus on is
just one small iota of this whole world
of informatics
which is bioinformatics which is deals
with molecular processes
uh proteins dna rna
and all of those things right so that's
what we're going to focus on
now what is bioinformatics right
each one of us can come up with a
definition this is like a 50 year old
definition
it is pretty much information you have a
mouse
and you apply to biology and so you just
bioinformatics it's about computer and
mouse this was a traditional definition
that was used about 20 years ago
right but now national institutes of
health
has come up with a definition which is
all very very wordy right
at the end of the day it's about data
how we acquire the data how we store
this data how we organize our drive
analyze and visualize
this is just too complicated for me
right this is just a big if you were to
write an exam
to memorize such a big definition of
bioinformatics is just a lot but
i'm going to in the next uh several
sites we are going to come up with what
actually is bioinformatics and this will
tie to
everything elia was talking about the
whole
proteomics and all the different omics
terms
right so this is biological data how do
you
do um experimentation in the computer
that's why this is called genomics in
virtual genomics which means we're doing
all the experimentations within a
computer
right so computer calculations and what
comes out of all of these things